support for retired Supreme Court
Justice Sandra Day O'Connor is pouring
in after she announced that she has the
beginning stages of dementia probably
Alzheimer's disease O'Connor who is now
88 said in a letter yesterday she's no
longer able to participate in public
life due to her condition she wrote
while the final chapter of my life with
dementia may be trying
nothing has diminished my gratitude and
deep appreciation for the countless
blessings in my life
in 1981 O'Connor made history when she
became the first woman appointed to the
Supreme Court she spoke to Scott Pelley
about that in 2004 I just see the
appointment of a woman to this Court
as a door opener for women across our
land and I think that's an incredible
legacy O'Connor opened the door for the
three female justices now on the bench
she was the deciding vote in landmark
cases on women's rights affirmative
action and campaign finance the
announcement comes 12 years after she
retired to care for her husband who
developed Alzheimer's disease dr.
Gayatri Devi is a neurologist at New
York's Lenox Hill Hospital who
specializes in memory disorder disorders
good morning good morning so justice
O'Connor said she was diagnosed some
time ago with dementia
what's the progression once the
diagnosis happens well you know
progression varies from person to person
and someone like her who is now 88 years
old who if she was diagnosed I'm
assuming a few years ago the progressive
progression should be very good
prognosis should be good because she is
older she's very articulate she has a
good brain a good cognitive reserve all
of which protects against rapid
acceleration over time so I think in her
case progression in my opinion would be
slow what does that mean in terms of
yeah about what John's asking to and in
terms of years what do you mean by that
I think the thing that most of us worry
about when we develop Alzheimer's which
is more feared by Americans older
Americans than cats
is that you are going to lose yourself
you're going to lose your soul and I
think that in a case like this where
someone has it much later in life the
likelihood is very high that she's not
going to lose herself she's not going to
lose her soul and she's going to
continue to know who she is and the
people around her until until the end of
her days I think if people are living
longer thus you see that a concern that
they will in fact maybe develop
Alzheimer's two thirds of Alzheimer's
patients are women why is that why does
it affect women women are affected more
by Alzheimer's for a multi multitude of
reasons first of all women live longer
so there are more women with Alzheimer's
secondly it seems as though women
survive more with cerebral vascular
disease of the brain compared to men who
died earlier with it and so that causes
disease in the brain which predisposes
to Alzheimer's disease and then there
are also the hormonal changes that women
are now living much longer without the
protective effects of estrogen and that
can also increase risk the other thing
too is that women suffer more as
caregivers from Alzheimer's disease as
did Justice Sandra Day O'Connor in that
she quit her job to take care of her
husband and that's something women tend
to do they tend to quit their jobs give
up their lives in order to take care of
loved ones with dementia doctor if you
are diagnosed is there anything or what
can one do to slow the progression so
first of all you have to realize there
are many different types of Alzheimer's
disease and depending on the part of the
brain that's affected and depending on
how old you are when you have it and
depending on the kind of brain that you
bring to the illness it can progress
differently and so there are things you
can do you can exercise eat healthy
stimulate the parts of the brain that
are failing that helps because you don't
use plasticity just because you have
Alzheimer's
we will honor her privacy and respect
her legacy doctor thank you so much
thank you